Lang chain is a framework designed to
simplify the creation of applications
using large language models it makes it
easy to connect AI models with a bunch
of different data sources so you can
create customized NLP applications
Rashad Kumar created this Lang sync
course for beginners he is an
experienced engineer and a great teacher
let's learn about what langchin is
sulang 10 is an open source framework
that allows developers working with AI
to combine large language models like
gpt4 with external sources of
computation and data the framework is
currently offered in Python in
JavaScript well typescript to be
specific and you can combine large
language models like gpt4 from open AI
or hugging phase to your own application
so it's an open source framework that
allows you to build you know AI llm
applications allows you to connect a
large language model like tpt4 to your
own sources of data and we are not
talking about you know pasting a snippet
of text into chat GPT prompt we're
talking about referencing an entire
database filled with your own data so it
could be you know a book that's in PDF
format that you have converted into the
right format for these llms to use which
are known as Vector databases and not
only that once you get all this
information you need you can have leg
chain to perform a certain Action For
You by integrating external apis so
let's say you want to send an email at
the end of you know whatever task you
did with your given data set and this is
where the kind of the main Concepts come
into play for the Lang chain framework
so I built this diagram to better you
know kind of understand the concepts so
you have three main kind of Concepts
you have components chains and agents So
within components you know we have llm
wrappers that allow us to connect to a
large language model like gpt4 or
hugging face then we have prompt
templates
prompt templates allows us to avoid
having to hard code text which is the
input to LLS
and then we have indexes that allows us
to extract the relevant information for
the other labs
the second concept is change the chains
allow us to combine multiple components
which are these here
together to solve a specific task and
build an entire application
and finally we have the agents that
allows llm to interact with its
environment and any of the external apis
remember how I talked about the task you
want to perform after you have retrieved
the information there is a lot to unpack
in Lang chain and new stuff is being
added every day but on a high level this
is what the framework looks like but I
have built you know kind of a demo app
as you know projects are the way that
all of this information basically sticks
talking about requirements for this
course so you will need python installed
and specifically version 3.8 or higher
and pip which is python package manager
a code editor so I'll be using visual
studio code but you can choose whatever
code editor of your choices
and also an open AI account since we'll
be using the open AIS llm today to build
our link chain applications I'll be
using a Windows machine so all of the
commands you'll see in the terminal will
be for Windows users but they are quite
similar on Mac OS or Linux systems so
let's start with the first thing which
is you'll need an openai account and in
order to sign up for an opening account
you can go to openai.com and click on
login this will take you to the login
screen
I already have an account signed up with
my Google account so I'll go ahead and
log in the reason why we need openai is
we will be using open AIS llm and we
need an API key so if you click on your
user account on the top right hand
corner you can click on view API Keys as
you can see I have generated a few of
them in your case you'll not see any API
keys so you can click on create new API
key
and this will give you a new openai API
key now remember to save that safely
somewhere because as you can see you
can't reveal the API key again so once
you create a new one it'll be only
revealed one time so save that and we'll
be using it later as an environment
variable in our code so now let me open
up my terminal here and what I'm going
to do is create the project directory
where our code will reside so I want to
make sure I'm in the right directory on
my computer here which is GitHub and
I'll create a new directory by typing in
the command mkdir and we'll call this
Lang chain Dash llm-app now let's change
our directory to our project directory
here and let me open it up in Visual
Studio code which is the editor of my
choice again you can use any code editor
that you like okay now that we have of
the project directory open in Visual
Studio code I'm just going to open up a
terminal in my visual studio code here
what I want to do now is create a
virtual environment so we'll be using
Python and we'll be creating a virtual
environment and you can do that by
typing python Dash mvnv and then dot VNV
so this is the command and then dot VNV
is the directory where the virtual
environment will exist and as you can
see on the right hand side where my
project directory is open we have a
folder now called dot V EnV and once we
have that prepared we'll need to
activate this virtual environment and
you can do that on Windows by typing in
E and V scripts and then
activate.ps1 which is a Powershell
script that will activate our virtual
environment as you can see there is a
green virtual environment text in the
front of the prompt so this means the my
virtual X environment has been active
and now we'll use pip which is a python
package manager to install the required
packages that we'll be using today so
I'm gonna do pip install and then Lang
chain openai streamlit and also python
dot EnV so Lang chain allows us to you
know work with Lang chain using python
open AI since we'll be using open Ai
zlnm and then streamlit allows us to
build interface for python applications
and you'll be seeing it how streamlit
makes it so easy to build interfaces and
then python.env allows us to use dot EnV
file which is where our openai API key
will reside safely as you know
environment variables in our python code
hit enter
okay so after some time all the packages
should be installed and you can see my
terminal is giving me a warning that a
new version of pip is available so if
you get same burning you can either
upgrade it or you can ignore the warning
for now I'll just hit clear so that my
terminal has a clear screen but also
I'll close it for now what I want you to
do is now create a main dot Pi file so
now we have main.pi we are python code
for the site so let's start by importing
Lang chain on the top and we'll be using
llms I want to use open AI again I'm
using open AI I know it will cost some
money and I'll show you in my openai
dashboard how much of the API calls cost
but it's in cents but it is the best one
if you want to use some other ones like
the open source hugging phase llm models
you can do that too Lang chin supports
it but right now I'm happy with openai
and also what I want to do is use dot
EnV the python.env package that we
installed to load our environment
variables and we can initiate that by
typing in load.env now I can go ahead
and create a DOT EnV file and save my
open AI underscore API underscore key as
an environment variable here and this is
where you will paste the SK Dash key
that was created in the openai dashboard
so let me do that and I don't want to
reveal my open AI API key okay so I
copied my API key from my open AI
account and pasted it in EnV file here
so I'll close that now what I want to do
with the first sample application here
is generate pet names so let's say I
have a pet dog and I want to generate
some cool names for it and maybe we'll
add few parameters where people can
select what kind of pet it is and maybe
color so let's to start with that
function so you can define a function in
Python by typing in Def and then we'll
call this generate underscore pet
underscore name and now we'll be using
llm from our Lang chain library and as I
said I'll be using openai today so this
has few properties one of them is
temperature now what temperature means
is how creative you want your model to
be so if the temperature is set to let's
say 0 it means it is very safe and it is
not taking any bets or risks but if it
is set to 1 it will be very creative and
will take risks and also might generate
wrong output but it is very creative at
the same time so I tend to set my
temperature to be 0.5 or 0.6 so that you
know it can get a little bit of creative
so let's set that by typing in
temperature
and now what I want to do is use this
llm to create cool names for my pet
which is in my case a DOT so I'll type
something like I have a dog pad and I
want cool names for it suggest me five
cool names so that's what our luncheon
app is gonna be it'll suggest five cool
names for your pet so let me type that
out as a prompt okay so I have my prompt
ready and this function will return the
name and now what we can do is if name
is equal to main which is you know
boilerplate python code
I wanted to print whatever that function
generates so generate pet name will be
printed in our console output so let's
give this a try by opening up the
terminal here and typing in Python main
dot py so as you can see it gave me five
names for my pet dog Apollo Blaze
Hershey Kona and Maverick which are
pretty good names and as you can see I
ended up setting the temperature to 0.7
so it's getting a little bit of creative
again you can you know test this out by
toggling this between 0 to 1 and see
what temperature suits your needs but
for me yeah 0.5 to 0.7 anything between
that is good since I need my llm to be a
bit creative so we just introduced one
component of Lang chain which is llm the
next thing that I want to introduce you
to is promptemplate so prompt templates
make it easy to generate these problems
so you don't have to keep asking openai
a different prompt every time right so
we want to repurpose this so that people
on the internet might be able to
generate pet names so maybe we will
create you know imagine that you want to
create a web app where people can
comment and read pet names we want to
repurpose this prompt and also we don't
want to hard code dog and if we want to
have pet color as an option we don't
want to hard code that so we want the
ability to repurpose our llm prompt for
different kind of animals and different
kind of colors and the way we can do
that is by using prompt templates so
prompt template name let's just call it
that and in Lang chain it's called
prompt template and we will also have to
import it from Lang change so going to
the top let's import prompt templates
okay so you're using Lang chin prompts
and importing prompt template now you
can see the squiggly line underneath it
has gone so let's give it to let's give
it an input variables so
input variables are the parameters that
can be dynamic so in our case it will be
animal type right so animal underscore
type and now we'll also have to add that
as a parameter to our python function
there we go so animal type is the input
variable and the template that our
prompt has is same as this so I'll copy
this and instead of a dog pet I will use
the input variable here which is animal
underscore type so now you can imagine
you can say hey I have a cat and some
other person comes and says hey I have a
cow pet and I want a cool name for it
suggest me five cool names so that is
what prompt templates allows you to do
and now we'll have to also get rid of
this and use chains as a concept so
that's import chain from Lang chain from
Lang chain dot chains import llm chain
what llm chain allows us to do is put
these individual components of Lang
chain together so llm and Prime template
in our case so llm chain llm is equal to
llm in our case because we named it and
prompt is equal to prompt template so
I'll just copy this so prompt template
name and instead of name let's call this
name chain right since this is an llm
chain and instead of returning name
let's create a response here
and that response basically will be name
underscore chain and we'll be using the
animal type parameter here right which
is basically whatever the animal type
the person specifies and will be
returning the response here so response
will be whatever this chain gives us the
output has right now let's try instead
of dog let's try cat right so we are
using parameters to print five cool pet
names using our name underscore chain
which is the llm chain using openai and
using this prompt template hit Ctrl s
and going back to my terminal here
let's run python main.py
so now you can see we are getting a Json
response with animal type which is cat
and the text that we got is so these are
the names that we got one is mochi or
Moki nacho Pebbles tiger and whiskers so
we got five names for our animal type
cat similarly you can try cow here hit
Ctrl s and run the python file again
now it says animal type was cow and the
text response is where our cow pet names
are so one is hambone Daisy moo Moody
Milky Way and give her hugs awesome so
the other parameter that I want to add
to our pet's name generator is the pet
color because I think that is an
important aspect when you name your pet
right so pet color and so we'll add pet
color as a parameter to our generate pet
names function but also we'll have to
add it as an input variable in our
prompt template so let's add fat color
over here there we go and now we'll also
have to change the template itself so I
have an animal type pet and I want a
cool name for it and let's add it is
whatever the color is so pet color
so maybe it's black in color suggest me
five cool names for my pet there we go
so that is our new prompt
hit control s and in the name chain
we'll also have to add the pet color
here so pet underscore color and that
will be equal to whatever the pad color
the person picks or says so now we can
run this by saying cow and our cow color
is black so let's let's try that out
toggle back my terminal here and type in
Python main.pi and you can see so we got
animal type cow pet color is black and
we received text response with those
five names so one is Shadow second is
midnight uh Starlight and we have Raven
awesome so our pet's name generator is
working as expected maybe I want to
publish this as web app later right and
that's where streamlib comes in
streamlit will build us a web interface
and we don't have to do much we can use
our python file here to build that
beautiful interface and then people can
come in and select whatever pet kind
they have and whatever pet color they
have and it would output those five
names utilizing the Lang chin app we
built so in order to do that what I I
want to do is instead of having all of
this code in main.pi I want to create
another file called Lang chain
underscore Helper and this is where all
our Lang chain code will go so I'm going
to go into main.pi Ctrl a to select all
the code and paste it in the langchin
helper file here and then we can clear
the main.pi so our main.pi is blank and
I have moved all my code to Lang chain
underscore helper.py hit Ctrl s so make
sure you have saved that and in main.pi
what I want to do is input our Lang
chain helper Library so we can do that
by doing Simple import statement on the
top so I'm importing Lang chain helper
as lch just short form so that I'll be
able to call our generate pet name
function by just using lch dot right
also remember we did pip install
streamlit in the beginning so we'll be
using that here too and I'll be calling
it throughout the python code AS SD
which is just short for streamlit so in
order to create our streamlit app you
can use different text types and you can
also use markdown which streamlit will
render but one of the main things is
having a title for our web interface and
you can do that by doing St dot title
and we'll call this pet's name
generator
right hit save and now I'll just show
you how to run a streamlined app where
you can do that is open the terminal and
type in streamlit run main.py hit enter
and let me open my browser on Port 8501
there we go so as you can see
right out of the box we have this
interface that was built using streamlit
and again if you haven't heard about
streamlit it's an amazing tool you can
go to streamlit.io and go through their
documentation on how to even make your
web app better since I'll be using some
basic components from streamlit to
display our pet's name generator
beautifully so let's get back to our app
here so back in our code editor I'll hit
Ctrl C in my terminal to stop the
streamlit app and bring my terminal down
and now we need some variables and Logic
for the ability for users to pick their
pets and the pet color so one of them is
the animal type right whether it's dog
cat or a cow will give a sidebar
selection for our users so SD dot
sidebar dot select box will allow you to
do that and you can input what the
question is so what is your pet question
mark and then you can include the
options so it will be a drop down where
people can select cat right dog and cow
and maybe a hen right so think of all
the pets then people that people can
have maybe hamster is more popular I
guess so cat dog cow hamster and then
you can just keep going so that is the
animal type and I can show you how this
looks on our streamlit apps so streamlit
space run space
so you can see that and I can zoom in a
little bit on the left hand side we have
a sidebar now and you can select what
kind of pet you have so what is your pet
the next logic that I want to build is
another option to select the color of
your pet but I want it in a way that
once you have selected the pad type so
animal type right if it's cat it should
say what color is your cat and we can do
that by if statements so if animal
underscore type is cat right I want pet
color which is another variable we pass
to our generate pet name function here
you can say pet color is equal to and
then we use the select box component
from streamlit to ask what color is your
cap now I feel like there can be
different variations so you can't just
put in black blue white orange
you know since with cows and even cats
and dogs you can have multiple colored
pets right like a white dog with black
spots on it so we can't have a select
box let's just keep this as a text to
you and I just thought of that as I was
building this right so instead of a
select box we have a sidebar with a text
area that asks for what color is your
cat and I also want to maybe have a
limit of Maximum characters that people
can put into this because remember we
are calling the open AI API and the API
calls depend on the amount of
information you are sending in the
prompt template so if our prompt gets
bigger we'll be charged more so in order
to limit that let's have a Max character
property here again this is available on
Shameless documentation and we'll use
the label ER so the label is what color
is your cat and the maximum characters
that users will be allowed to put in is
15 and we can hit save what you can do
is copy this over for dog cow so I'll
put dog here and what color is your dog
or dog for cow it will be what color is
your cow and then I think we're left
with one which is for hamster again I'll
just copy this and paste for hamster
okay there is an efficient way to do
this but I'm just gonna copy the code
that I already have go back to my
browser here refresh my streamlit page
and now you can see if we select dog it
will say what color is your dog and you
see the text area which has a limit of
15 characters similarly if you select
the cow you can see it asks
what color is your cup so both of the
parameters have been set right now what
I want to do is send this information to
our Lang chain helper right because this
is where it will generate those names
and give it back to us so let's do that
so after we have set the pet color
right because that's the last question
we ask our users what we want to do is
have a variable here called response
and response is equal to LC Edge which
stands which is just short for Lang
chain helper here and the function
in the Lang chain helper is generate pet
name
so I'll copy that over so you do lch dot
generate pet name so we are accessing
that function animal type was the first
parameter that we need again I'm using
animal type as a variable here maybe we
can
say user
underscore animal type and I'll have to
change that over here
over here over here and over here again
just so that you're not confused so
two parameters animal type and pet color
and then I'm using the user animal type
as a variable on our main.pi so user
underscore animal underscore type and
the second parameter is pet color again
you can do the same here so user
underscore pet underscore color and
you'll have to update all of these here
just to avoid confusion so we are
passing these variables that the user
said so user will say I have a dog and
its pet color is white and we are
passing those to our generate pet name
function and then we'll just write that
as a text field so our text Will field
will just reply with response so let's
save that
now let's go back to our browser here
hit refresh
now let's select dog and type in the
color black
and you can hit Control Plus enter to
apply
and you can see we got a response
with the five pet names right
and
what you can do to display this
beautifully
is set an output key right
so let's go back to our Lang chain
helper here and in the name underscore
chain We'll add a third property called
output key right and the output key is
pet underscore name so basically instead
of giving us a text output it will
associate those five names that it
generated to this output key and we can
access this in our main.pi so instead of
just returning the entire response so
the whole text here see how it looks
weird we'll just we'll just access the
names that it generated and we can do
that by doing response and then
accessing that
underscore name which was the Kiwi set
so hit Ctrl s go back to our browser
window and click refresh this time let's
go with the cat which is white hit
Control Plus enter to apply
and you can see it displays the text now
better right it looks beautiful and we
have the recommendations here as snowy
marshmallow cotton pull blizzard let's
go over the brown hamster so hamster
and brown Coco mocha Chestnut caramel
biscuit
love those names so now
as you can see we have a streamlit app
and we are using Lang chain to generate
five cool pet names for the pets that we
might have and we saw how you can use
another lamp prom templates and the
chain which are three main components of
Lang chain but now the important one
that's left is Agents right so agents
allow llms to interact with the
environment so think of apis or things
you want to do after Gathering the
information so going over the Lang chain
documentation about agents the core idea
of Agents is to use an llm to choose a
sequence of actions to take in Chains a
sequence of actions is hard coded in
code
whereas in agents a language model is
used as a reasoning engine to determine
which actions to take and in which order
and there are several key components
Langton provides a few different types
of agents to get started even then you
will likely want to customize those
agents depending on the personality of
the agent and the background context you
are giving to the agent and then there
are tools so tools are functions that an
agent calls there are two important
considerations giving the agent access
to the right tools and describing the
tools in a way that is most helpful to
the agent so let's test it out so we
already have a pet's name generator
thing that's working for us right gives
us a name for our pet
now let me create another function here
which will name Lang chain underscore
agent and before we can interact with
the agent we have to import the Lang
chain Agents from the framework so you
can do that by adding these three import
statements on top so we are importing
tools we are also importing the
initialization of the agent and the
agent type so coming back to our
function here so first we'll Define the
llm that we want to use and I still want
to use the openai llm and the
temperature will set it to 0.5 here and
then we can load some tools
that will perform the given action so
there are various tools that are
available and again you can go through
the availability of tools or the list of
tools on the link chain documentation
but I'll be using Wikipedia which will
be the first tool I want to use and I'll
get to it why I want to use Wikipedia
and the other one is llm matte because I
want to perform some matte and this is
to just showcase what agents can do
right and then the llm that we'll be
using is defined here which is the open
AI so llm is equal to llm right and now
we'll have to initiate the agent so
agent and to initialize its initialize
underscore agent
and here you specify the tools that will
be providing it which is stored right
here which is Wikipedia and lmat the llm
we want to use right
and the agent type so one of the agent
types that's available in the quick
start guide for langchain is the react
and you can go to the agent types
documentation here so zero shot react is
the one that I'll be using decision uses
react framework to determine which tool
to use based solely on the tools
description so heading over to our code
and the way you define that agent type
is by setting it here and we'll set the
verbose flag to True which means it'll
show us the reasoning that'll happen in
our console so that's the agent we want
and we'll create a result here where we
run the agent and now you can specify
the tasks so you want to perform through
this agent so since our app is solely
based on pets let's ask it what is the
average age
of a dog and I'll ask it to do some math
and that is the reason why I loaded the
llm math tool here multiply the age by
three and at the end we'll print result
so that looks good and I will change
this so I'll comment this out instead
we'll print whatever this generates so
Lang chain agent right hit save and now
we can run this and just to demonstrate
it I'll not be
linking this to our streamlit app which
was the web interface I'll just run the
Lang chain underscore helper python file
just to Showcase you how agent works so
before I do that I have to make sure
that Wikipedia is installed through pip
so pip install Wikipedia will install
that python Library so now if I run the
langchin helper file we'll see the agent
in action okay so you'll see that it
finished the chain and the answer was
the average of a dog is 45 years when
multiplied by three but the final answer
that it got was 15 right so the average
age of the dog is 15 and then it
multiplied by 3 which is 45. so you can
see that it was able to grab the
information from Wikipedia which is 15
as the average age of a dog and it was
also able to perform the math and get to
this right and now since we set the
verbose flag to true you can see the
reasoning that went into it right and
I'll increase my terminal and with no
size here and get rid of the file
explorer on the right so you can see
I need to find out the average age of a
dog action is Wikipedia action input is
averages of talk and this is the
observation that it found right so it
did scan few pages on Wikipedia
thought I now know the average age of a
dog and the age of the oldest dog right
and then action is calculator where it's
trying to multiply 15 which is the
average age by three because that's what
we asked it to do awesome so that's how
the agents work and I believe we have
kind of covered almost all components
within the langchin framework the only
thing that's left is indexes right so
what are indexes basically as you can
see we are still working with the open
AI llm but we are also not providing any
of the custom knowledge right so we are
still relying on open Ai and the
information that they have gathered but
with langchain you can also provide your
own knowledge or knowledge base on which
you can ask llm to do certain actions so
think of a PDF file or even URLs that
you can script or maybe you have a large
PDF file with a lot of text and maybe
you want to run an llm AI chat bot for
your own document so you can do that
with the help of language in the next
project that I want to showcase you will
exactly do that will take a long YouTube
video so think of a podcast which is
hours long or a long YouTube video right
so what I have here is
the Microsoft CEO certain dealer full
interview on recode but it's 51 minutes
long and what I want to do with Lang
chain is the ability to ask questions to
this video so the context that the llm
would have is strictly of that video and
I'll be using few libraries like YouTube
transcript which basically converts
whatever URL we provide for a YouTube
video and gets its transcript right so
let's build this YouTube assistant now
I'm going to show you how you can create
this assistant that can answer questions
about a specific YouTube video so coming
back to the concept of indexes I touched
briefly on it but we also saw it in the
Lang chain diagram but we know that
these large language models become
really powerful when you combine them
with your own data and your own data in
this scenario will be the YouTube
transcript that we are going to download
automatically but you can basically
replace that transcript with any
information in this approach so it could
be a PDF it could be blog post URL right
so what Langton offers is document
loaders
and I can quickly show you the YouTube
transcript one so this is the YouTube
transcript and basically it allows you
to get the transcript which will be the
text version of the YouTube video right
but there are several other document
loaders that you can see on the left
hand side right so you can bring in an
S3 file you could bring an Azure blob
storage file you could do Hacker News
posts or articles right so these are
some of the document loaders that are
supported by linkchin as of now and
we'll be using text Splitters and Vector
stores so we are going to use these
three components to load our YouTube
video transcript split it into smaller
chunks and then store it as Vector
stores so you can think of these as
little helper tools that will make it
easy for us to load the transcript which
might be thousands of lines of text so
to get us started what I have already
done is created a YouTube assistant
directory so not be using the pets
generator directory that we had and what
I have done is pretty similar to the
pet's name generator right so I have
main.pi which will hold our streamlit
interface and then the langchin helper
will have the length chain components
and I've also created a virtual
environment and installed all the
necessary packages which is link chain
openai YouTube transcript also I've I
went ahead and created dot EnV file
which holds my openai API key so pretty
similar to the pet's name generator and
now we can start with the lag chain
helper first so the first thing that we
are going to import is the YouTube
loader that we saw right which is a
document loader so from langtin dot
document loaders we are importing that
YouTube loader and the second important
thing we need is the text splitter so as
I showcased that the video that I have
is 51 minutes long you could also pick
up a podcast like Lex and they have
podcasts that are three hours long and
which means you'll have thousands of
lines and that is where we'll use the
the text splitter to break down those
huge transcripts into smaller chunks and
I'll show you how and for the rest of
the inputs we are gonna input the lag
chain components like the llm which will
be open AI prompt template and llm chain
the other thing
coming back to indexes we'll be using
Vector stores so I'll be using the phase
library and
I'll quickly show you what the face
library is phase is a library by meta or
Facebook for efficient similarity search
and you might have heard of other Vector
stores or databases like Pinecone or vv8
right but I'll be using phase for this
project so let's start with writing some
code so I've done all the necessary
inputs here the only input that's left
is the dot EnV which will load our
environment variables and I'll initiate
dot EnV here also since I'll be using
openai embeddings so we'll initiate that
to here and I forgot to import those so
I'll import the open aim bearings and
now we can create our first function to
create a function we know that in Python
it's deaf and let's name this function
that will be be creating a vector DB
create Vector DB from YouTube so that's
a pretty big function name right but I
want to specify what we are doing and
we'll be using phase here also for the
parameter let's give this a required
parameter which is the video URL right
so we'll be pasting this video URL in
our streamlit interface and that's what
we'll be using and this will be a string
right so the first thing we want to do
is load the YouTube video from the URL
right so we'll use loader which we
imported on the top so YouTube loader
Dot from YouTube URL and we'll pass the
video URL parameter here after we have
loaded the YouTube video I want to save
this into the transcript variable so
we'll create transcript here and we'll
just do loader dot load and this should
give us the transcript now we'll be
using text splitter and I'll
specifically tell you why so text
splitter and we imported it here as
recursive character text splitter you
can specify few parameters
when using this so the first one is
chunk size
which will set to 1000 and chunk overlap
so chunk size is how much each chunk
will contain so for me it will be 1000
right and then overlap is once it has
created those individual docs from the
long transcript it'll have an overlap in
every document so document one the last
hundred words would also be included in
the document twos first hundred words
right so that is what overlap is
and now we'll save them into a docs
variable so text underscore splitter not
split documents as the function and
we'll provide the transcript that we had
loaded from the YouTube url there we go
okay
now let's also initiate the phase so
phase Dot from documents and we will be
using docs which we stored here right
docs and we'll be using the open Ai
embeddings and we'll return this DB
okay
so now on to the explanation why we have
to split the text so basically what we
are doing at the text splitter is we
have taken over thousands of lines and
split up the documents so it has taken
very large transcript over and split it
up into chunks of 1000 so that is the
first step now you might wonder right so
we can't just provide thousand lines to
the open AI API remember there is a
token size or a limit on how much
information you can send to open AIS API
and that is why we have split the amount
of context we'll be sending for for a
YouTube transcript right because the
model that I'll be using is the text
DaVinci 003 and as you can see it can
only take
4097 tokens so I cannot send the entire
transcript to open aiz Ai and that is
why we'll be splitting it and storing it
into Vector stores
again this is quite technical I'll not
go into much detail but vectors
basically are a numerical representation
of the text we just created here right
so the core responsibility of this
function is to load the transcript right
take all the text that's in the
transcript split it into smaller chunks
and then save those chunks as Vector
stores again we can't just provide all
of these Vector stores to the open AI
right we can't just send over the 10 000
or maybe even 50 chunks that we have
created of smaller text that's where
we'll use phase to do a similarity
search right and that's what the next
function will be and before I write that
next function we'll see if this works so
video underscore URL so I'm gonna hard
code the video URL that we have for the
podcast and see if we get the smaller
chunk documents right so let's print
this function at the end
hit save and we'll open the terminal
make sure your virtual environment is
activated and you have installed the
required packages again all of this will
be available on GitHub for reference
later but let's run the line chain
helper python file again it'll take some
time to do the computation
I missed to write print so we'll have to
print this whatever this function
returns which should be the database
that we created right so let's run it
again and this time we should get the
vector stores that were created and so
instead of DB if I return docs you'll
see those chunks
so if I expand my terminal here you can
see we have quite a few text here but
here are the docs right so you can see
that there's a document and then it
starts with the content and you'll see
multiple document chunks so these are
the chunks that we created from the
larger transcript so this is one right
this is the second one
and so on I know the formatting is weird
so you can't really tell where the new
document starts but yeah this is all the
chunks that we have awesome so our
function to create the vector DB from
YouTube url is working as expected so
I'll get rid of this print statement and
full return DB here now for the next
function which is going to be getting
off the response on our query we have to
ask this YouTube video right so let's
create that function we'll name it get
underscore response from query again
pretty self-explanatory name for the
function itself and we'll pass few
parameters to this function one is DB
the important one will be query which
will be the question that the user asks
and K which is another argument that
I'll go over this is used for the
similarity search that will do so keep
in mind the amount of tokens that the
text DaVinci 3 Model can take right so
keep that in mind it's 4097 so I'll just
add a comment here saying text DaVinci
can handle 2097 tokens right now in
order to do a similarity search we'll
save that into a docs variable within
this function so DB
is what we'll use we'll perform a
similarity search on the DB which is the
database we created in the previous
function so gb.similarity underscore
search and the search will be basically
the query so the first thing I want to
do with this function is basically
search the query relevant documents so
let's say in this podcast they talk
about a ransomware somewhere so right
here they talk about ransomware right
and if I want to ask a question saying
what did they talk about ransomware so
my query is just about ransomware that
that they talked about in the podcast so
it will only search the document that
has details about ransomware so we'll
not send the entire documents that were
created but just the one that is
relevant to the query that the user made
I hope that makes sense and this is also
where we'll pass the K as argument and
I'll tell you what K is so remember that
we can have
4097 tokens but our chunk size is 1000.
so that means we can kind of send four
documents right because each document is
a size of thousand so let's set that
value to four okay so we'll be sending
four relevant docs based on the query
that the user made now I'll create
another variable called docs page
content
and what we'll basically do is join
those four docs that we'll be sending
okay so we got those four docs and we
are joining them to create one dock
because the Toca limit is 4097 and here
we'll almost have 4 000 tokens being
sent to the text DaVinci 3 mod awesome
now let's work with the llm right so
pretty similar to what we did with the
pet's name generator we'll initiate the
llm to be open Ai and
as I said the model that I'll be using
is text DaVinci 3 so let me go to the
open AIS documentation copy this model
name come back here and paste it and
there is some white space at the end so
we'll get rid of that and the second
thing we did with the pets name
generator was prompt right so prompt
templates is the is another main
component of Lang chain so we'll use
that and this is variable define what
the prompt should be for the open AI llm
so the first thing would be to specify
the input variables right so the first
one is question or query right so
whatever the question is being asked by
the user in Docs
so docs is basically the similarity
search we did there we go now the
template that we'll be using is a prompt
that I've created here so I'm gonna copy
this really quick since it's a long
prompt okay so I've copied the prompt
basically it says you're a helpful
YouTube assistant that can answer
questions about videos based on the
videos transcript right
answer the following question and this
is where the input variable goes
whatever the question the user is asking
by searching the following video
transcript which is the docs right so
docs is basically the similarity search
we did
only use factual information from the
transcript to answer the question if you
feel like you don't have enough
information simply say I don't know
right because we don't want the AI or
the llm to hallucinate your answer
should be needed so that is basically
the prompt that we'll be using to answer
questions and now we'll be using another
main component which is chain within the
Lang chain so let's create an llm chain
where llm is equal to llm because we
specified it here that will be using
openai model text DaVinci 3 and prompt
is equal to prompt which we specified
here using prompt template okay now
we just have to learn the response so
I'll create a variable call response it
will do chain dot run which will
basically run our chain since we had
question as the input variable here
we'll say that question is equal to
query
because that's what we were referring to
it on the previous function and
Docs
is equal to docs page underscore content
remember because we joined all the
four documents because K is set to 4 to
be one doc because we can we have the
ability to send four thousand tokens and
then response is equal to response
dot replace and this is just some
formatting that we have to do because
if you remember in the pet's name
generated to the response we were
getting
was in one line and it included new line
characters so we'll replace that with
some white space and we'll return
response okay so now we can test this
out as it is in the console by hard
coding the question and the URL which we
already did so let's get ready for that
but also build the interface because
it'll be really quick with streamlit so
coming over to our main dot Pi let's do
some inputs on the top so pretty similar
to what we did in our pets named
generator so streamlit I'm importing it
as St and the langchain helper where are
all of the Lang chain code is and I'm
also importing text wrap basically it
gives you the ability to wrap text so
that you're not you don't have to scroll
the page the title of this page will be
YouTube assistant right so YouTube
assistant
and now on the sidebar we can have those
parameters that we need from the user
with sidebar I want to create a farm so
we have a submit button at the end so SD
dot form is how you do that
and you also have to specify a key so
key is my form again this is all
streamlit stuff and let me know in the
comments if I should create a course on
streamlit on how to build you know cool
python interfaces I love this tool
because I don't have to care about
building a front end and the first
parameter we had in our length chain
helper was the YouTube url right so
we'll save that as video URL so YouTube
url
is equal to SD dot sidebar text
as we used in the pet's name and we'll
just say that the label is what is the
YouTube video URL and we'll give a Max
to maximum character limit of 50 because
I don't think a video URL can exceed 50
characters uh the other parameter we had
was the question that the user can ask
and we'll save it as query here so St
dot sidebar dot text underscore area
right and then the label will be asked
me about the video so again you can have
a limit here right so maybe you can only
ask questions that are not long enough
so we'll set max characters 50 here too
and also set the key to query here okay
and at the last since I created this as
a form we'll give it a submit button and
the label here will be submit now
so if Kiri which is the question the
user can ask and YouTube url exist right
what I want to do is basically run this
function to give us the answer right so
we'll be as we are already importing the
link chain helper on the top as LS lch
so that's what we'll be using here so DB
which is the database will be equal to
so remember we have to pass the video
URL uh to the create Vector DB function
to create a new Vector database based on
the transcript that we got so DB is
equal to lch which helps which is
basically that we are accessing this
python file and then the create Vector
DB from YouTube url function and we'll
pass the YouTube url
as the parameter because remember we
just need the video URL here response
comma docs is equal to and now we'll get
a response which we can do by running
this function which is get response from
query and remember the parameters that
will be passing so lch dot getresponse
from query the first one is DB which we
just created right and query is the
question that I will be asking so
um right here whatever the user asks
will be the query
so I am missing a comma here as I'm
going through my code so I'll add that
and now we'll save that response in our
interface with streamlit so let me
create a sub header here which will say
answer right and below that we'll have
St dot text
and we'll wrap that text
and this is where the text wrap library
is being used you'll you'll see this in
the interface once I run it so text wrap
dot fill and whatever the response we
get from the length chain function
you can also set the width of this text
area to be 80 let's go with 80 and see
how that looks
and that is basically it so two
parameters for necessary one is the
YouTube video URL and the question that
the user asks right and we are passing
so if the both of those parameters exist
first we are creating the database from
the YouTube video URL and then we're
getting the response based on the
question that the user asked using the
llm so now we can run our streamlit app
after saving the file so if I scroll
down to the bottom here for my terminal
expand this and run stream lit run
main.pi
hit enter
it should load our web interface for our
streamlit app awesome
on the left hand side you can see we
need to provide a YouTube video URL so
I'll just go ahead copy this interview
video URL paste it here
ask me about the video so let's say what
did they talk about rent somewhere is
what I want to know
and hit submit okay so we have got some
errors saying input variables let's go
to our terminal and see if we have any
logging
okay so I found the error I was just
missing S I thought I typed it right
so instead of input variable it needs to
be input variables and we'll Ctrl C to
stop our streamlit app and do streamlit
run run main.pi again so after adding
the S hit enter and now
we need the same exact information so
copy this
and copy the question so the YouTube
video URL and what did they talk about
ransomware hit submit
there we go we got our answer so it says
they discussed how ransomware is
difficult to track due to zero day
exploits and how Microsoft is making it
a mission to help with secure cloud
backup for Enterprises better tracking
of zero day exploits and helping with
enforcements they also discussed the
importance of public-private
Partnerships in order to prioritize
cyber security and create new standards
such as those for nist so
remember our prompt I asked it to be as
detailed as possible also say I don't
know if it doesn't know
what the answer is based on the
transcript we provided and not to
hallucinate so I think this is a pretty
good answer
um that we got out of this 52 minute
video again you can pick a longer video
and ask about anything specifically
longer from podcasts right maybe the
video is four to five hour Longs and you
need to know a specific detail I think
that's where this tool or the app we
build can be really handy
right but yeah so we learned a lot about
Lang chain today specifically the main
three main components which is llm so
any of the large language models that
you can use like open AI or hugging face
prompt templates right
and chains so how you can combine these
components into chains to perform the
required task and agents right remember
in the pets generator we talked a little
bit about agents
and how they have reasoning behind the
tasks that they perform because we try
to calculate average age of a dog and
also multiply it by three so it used
Wikipedia and llm math to get those
answers but also we learned a bit about
indexing and Vector stores so how you
can split large
documents into smaller chunks and store
it as Vector which is basically you know
numerical representation of the
documents that we created and then
passing those on to the llm since there
are certain limits of how much context
you can send to the API but yeah one
other thing I would like to mention is
if you are planning to make these apps
public remember we were storing our
environment variables in dot EnV file
and you might be wondering every ship I
also created an openai API key like how
much all of this is going to cost so
I'll go into my dashboard in into
billing to see how much did it cost me
to you know basically kind of build this
course out so you can see
um
10 cents and 30 cents so very close to
less than a dollar like half of a Dollar
close to 50 cents is what it costed me
to make all of these queries to the
openai llm the thing I was gonna
recommend if you want to publish this
app so that the public can use it
is to have a field here uh you know with
the sidebar saying open AI API key so
that the users have to submit their
openai API key with their app so you can
have a text field here saying hey what
is your open AI API key just so that you
know you are not being charged and you
can make that as a secret field so that
the key is not displayed in the
interface but you can use that key to
make these queries you will just have to
pass it in the Lang chain helper so
whatever the variable name you decide
maybe like open AI API key which you'll
get the value from our streamlit
interface you can pass that right here
when you initiate the large language
model so
you'll specify openai API key as a
parameter here and the value of that key
which will be the variable you decide so
yeah that's pretty much it for this
course again we learned quite a bit
about the langchin framework
specifically in Python uh you know the
models prompts indexes chains and agents
or the five main Concepts within nag
chain that I wanted to cover again I
hope this helps you understand the
framework itself and how you can utilize
this information to build something
really cool with the power of llms but
if you would like to see a streamlit
course again let me know in the comments
but I hope you find this course helpful
I'll see you in the next one peace